oh I thought just I couldn't you know
discount it was like a big deal when I
was a kid obviously still is and and I
was at dinner I my mate was like you
need to stop looking at him he was sort
of there and I was just having dinner
and it's just well I think she was
specially like babe you really like
focus you need to focus and not just be
staring at my mic
I met Cate Blanchett the other night and
I was I was nervous but I held my own I
think she's just one of the she's the
greatest actresses of all time so that
was thrilling so it's different because
it stands alone as something you don't
need to have seen any other Star Wars
movie to enjoy it get it
so this underworld is if the gangster
under what's about Han Solo which is so
there hasn't been fully explored so it
was sort of new ground which gave it a
little bit less pressure maybe
you know I wasn't I was alive when the
first Star Wars came out I remember in
1977 remember it vividly people were
just going crazy about this movie
everybody was talking about it it was
all the rage I proceeded down to the
theater and saw it and it was very
illuminating I just had never seen a
movie like it I've never seen characters
like that like millions of others I fell
in love with it at least she just said
the average on an interview and then had
to apologize for see me effort in an
interview and then kept saying it and he
kept saying I'm quite I do swear quite
oh no I can't
oh yeah I just okay yeah I'm gonna do my
best work in hello genuinely gonna try
this time and it's gonna be embarrassing
because it's not gonna be funny bad it's
just gonna be mildly average oh I can't
just I can't
it's how do you enough onset you know I
mean even in my head I'm really good at
advice cons do it can't do a quickie
well you see okay what returns
I'm afraid given that that's just for me
anyway that's it that's the end of the
show you ready and all good things must
come to an end I became the most
unpopular person in England at that on
that particular day because it was the
UK team versus the rest of the world the
UK team was very strong and never lost
so scoring that final victory goal
penalty kick felt good but I noticed
that there was absolute silence in the
stadium I had to look back at my team I
thought I'd done something wrong and
they were all just charging toward me
excited
[Music]
something cold snack oh I should call
Ashley Cole